alors je suis monsieur patrick barth est
donc je suis en vacances à la réunion
depuis le mois de mars et vu que je suis
un passionné du chemin de fer que je
suis en métropole toujours dans les
temps et bien à la réunion pourquoi pas
on continue dans les trains et je suis
en train de préparer l'itinéraire pour
aller à
l'ancienne garde de l'étang salé qui est
aujourd'hui un office de tourisme et
dans cette gare de l'étang salé il y a
un truc que spéciale qui est unique à
cette gore et nous allons donc avait
visité sept cette chose rare
[Musique]
le voyage à corps jaune se passe bien
tant qu'on y est on est bien assis
confortablement
voilà alors au niveau de la
fonctionnalité il ya aucun traitement
j'ai toujours eu le bus en temps et en
heure le problème qui est du bouchon qui
soit à saint paul ça nous fait prendre
du retard abominable à l'arrivée de sony
mais sinon
franchement il n'y a vraiment rien à
dire au niveau des
horaires et des correspondances qui vont
bien qu'ils vont bien
[Musique]
richard baret
milena nouvelle arrivée à saint louis
mais ça va prendre car je ne peux aller
travailler dans un premier temps mais
prends mon nous saleté numéro 21 jusqu'à
la gare août et 6 nuits après me
reprends le haut 2 à la garrotxa 500
0,10 ou aller
au lycée alakagni travail social se
réduit
[Musique]
mais non nous apprend le haut 2 car
jaune poussin coeur
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
oui
le service est important parce que me
direz que les personnes après moyen de
transport que les vieux solvay déplaça
zone c c'est l'idéal que l'on peut se
détacher
c'est un bon
dire que les pratiques il permet à moi
d'aller travailler parce que ma part mon
père ni soldats mais aussi d'aller aussi
va comme et loisirs soit bien que les
déplacements quotidiens
[Musique]
bonjour fabien mais aux étudiants en
master vi l'environnement sur le tampon
est aujourd'hui là on va prendre le bus
depuis chez moi dans l'ess à ses épaules
jusqu'aux tempes et l'a31 à 2 depuis sa
pole de cas j'en apprends hélas ne sera
stocks mais là c'est direction à la gare
de saint paul pour prendre le bus pour
aller dans le sud
[Musique]
ce
m
[Musique]
l'anecdote
des tas de scénarios nam
tu alignes par les berlines
pierre boulez tranquille c'est là que
notre un cours d autres apprennent entre
simplicité
là où la route je plusse avait explosé
c'est pas nouveau
après valence ne l'a pas attendu
longtemps dans l'un des nôtres puceul au
plus vite
pernod donc voilà
la nouvelle à votre
mari fait la rue saint-pierre depuis
saint paul dans la rue prennent plus la
lune s2 pour la motion tampon et là on
arrive à la fin
[Musique]
c'est
tu
disque allait pourtant notamment que
nous les étudions vu que valve en terme
de free sur l'année une bénéficient de
créatures et une passe ben c'est les
avantages que nous et aussi un peu tout
ça la polo pmi ou tout ça tu économises
les sens mais voilà le cas j'en ai quand
même important